[Music]
in extorting team means wool exporting
team start them to deserve it no I'd
seen that's excluding people perfect the
other person deserve it there you go
submitted by headhunter yes thunder
rolls had murderer or you suck a lot of
dick or they're just trying to look for
people to work for their company oh [ __ ]
you think about that find people jobs or
they ate bebo help it's all extreme
except first a team caught scamming
online will be given one year to turn
his life around or face jail
remember when scamming used to be called
like when you're kissing yes oh my god
yeah sorry yeah Maggie Maggie
but macking was also like picking up a
girl or like skies of Mackin are you
pair enough to mix so there's a group of
four teams damn for 114 damn there was a
16 year old 17 year old and 18 year olds
and I believe the last one is another 17
year old that they don't clarify oh
that's wonderful
so what these Kim said is that they
created a fake account on Grindr the
likes of gay dating website or app it's
like a tinder but you grind with men
there's no lesbians on there I'm not
sure I just know it's mainly marketed
for men scarred and so what they did is
they created these fake accounts and
they lured these men to meet in certain
locations and then once they got there
they would take photos of them blackmail
them and say if you don't give us money
in your phone we're going to release
this and pretty much blackmailing them
these men why would they were safe like
dirty [ __ ] because they're saying that
they were going to be calling them
pedophile since these kids are under 18
they were luring them with themselves as
bait they were luring them with
themselves as fakes other men so they
didn't know that there were teens
victims didn't know their routine
well they had like the conversation was
like well I thought you were an adult
you tricked me
this is my proof that you're trying to
extortion me yeah and then I would just
call the cops
yes sir then that's when eventually a
was an undercover detective that was
posing as one of the victims or he was
just a gay guy that's also a cop he also
happens to be a cop and he's like gotcha
[ __ ] yeah he's like God wasn't on
Grindr because I enjoyed it it was for
investigation yeah I find [ __ ] like
you lost it word you don't know how many
dicks I had to suck under investigation
I didn't like it undercover stalkers
here we go he took over one of the
victims social media accounts so it's
someone that had already been extorted
by these teams so this detective took
over and then that's when they agreed to
meet up at a certain place in McConnell
these teams please [ __ ] why would they
give them a whole year to do that they
should just [ __ ] set in the jail
right now so right here we're talking
about the 16 year old the other people
that's a whole another story but just
for this particular 16 year old they're
saying like we'll say went to court that
they found evidence of images that this
team have photoshopped together with all
know the kids on face on the on a
depiction of Jesus crisis body holding
the head of one of the victims in his
hands and the caption read call me God
essay which just takes place in
Australia so apparently what essay means
it's like another word for like bro are
they not afraid of like revenge or
anything or like that did they all get
caught they all for any kids did get
caught because I think as a lesson um
you know they should state jail until
they're 18 yes
but right when they turn 18 all the guys
that they made horny should [ __ ] them
all I agree with exactly I was going to
say what I was going to say that instead
of going to jail they should get
butt-fucked until they're 18 all of that
that's what they're wishing upon
themselves right there China they're
like oh we're going to catch these
imaginary pedophiles be kind of dumb
pedo hunters yeah so if you want to be
bait and this is what you want and this
is how you're scamming innocent people
then you're just going to get but folks
can get exactly what you want
well if are they peddle hunters though
do they really catch pedophiles now
you're scaring people yeah opposing us
peddle hunters not clean and it even led
one of the
oh that means they should go to jail
yeah I don't think they should have this
one-year reform I throw way too
conniving they know exactly what they're
doing especially if they're
photoshopping doing all this stuff it's
not one of those like oh how was this
lost teen I didn't really know what I
got myself into like they had a
strategic plan it's premeditated so I
think they should all get butt-fucked by
RINO how much money did they make I
don't mention any money you should
attend Australia is it not sure but
going back on we are interesting so in
the court for this 16 year old in
particular they had a Sai current
psychiatric report that revealed to them
an immature neglected boy with serious
learning and other difficulties was in
part motivated to get money to buy food
oh he's so poor to need to buy food
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] this is
Australia this is not [ __ ] India this
is not the [ __ ] Republic of Congo the
ringleader is a 17 year old they says
like he's a lingerer because he had this
entire dossier of like all of the social
media accounts every single victim how
much money they made and everything
stuff we'll put in enough work to start
an online business yeah so I don't buy
that [ __ ] food [ __ ] and they
pretty much fooled adults now all right
watered was a kangaroo hotdog I'm so
poor hungry I could abuse [ __ ] bad [ __ ]
psychiatry should be fired before by
kids
the only rightful punishment is that he
get tied to a tree and a kangaroo kicks
him in his chest at times oh oh just
like that all happy circle but it has to
be that muscular zinger though that both
works well for now I crash the bucket in
the mark kangaroos yeah ask your guru
[Laughter]
my guru [ __ ] Q yeah yeah so this
looks Carroll in the car was Hank
released his lawyer was just saying that
he was completely remorseful and all you
understand the lawyer should get his
[ __ ] nuts chopped off I don't like
that I don't think people should to do
something this genius ago all I learn
laughs and I realized what the [ __ ] I
did wrong that's fine that's the best of
prerequisite you still need to go
through the punishment of everything
that we created especially premeditated
crime yep if it's like in the heat of
the moment or like really like got
caught up in confusion that's fine but
pre like having a list of social media
accounts creating fake Grindr accounts
Photoshop being like this is a lengthy
process and people that have made so
many active choices to scamming people I
think they should skip all that justice
for somebody died yeah I [ __ ] up
there's a lot of venomous snakes in
Australia and I think every day they
should get bit by a venomous snake on
their dick and then the anti-venom right
when they're about to die and then they
get brought back to life they also had
large spiders that should sit on their
face every night yeah the 17 year old
was sentenced in 19 months in jail he's
already been serving time for he only
needs to serve about three more months
you do all this crime in Australia and
you only get a year that's a [ __ ]
Bhushan go back to the 16 year old
though they said they're giving him a
year to get his [ __ ] together that the
judge is going to be checking in on him
every three months in school making sure
he does so [ __ ] lenient over there
make sure you do all your homework I
know you [ __ ] tortured and [ __ ] up
all these guys lives and you even caused
one to kill himself but you know what as
long as you're getting a 3.0 it's okay
with me yeah because if you get it back
to the face every morning for three
months I'm pretty sure you won't do that
[ __ ] again okay I think they need better
reform programs because this is pretty
much propaganda for all criminals to
just move to Australia
oh it's leaning over there I should
scare people and I start to do well in
school you know it's ironic what that's
how Australia started what any good news
yeah so now they're attracting more
criminals I like Australia so I don't
want to see stuff like this happens and
you know what for a land full of
criminals it's such a safe country
bagging a I know but you would think
that the descendants of criminals would
just continue on with the criminal stuff
but they ended up organizing and like
making stuff better yeah we all decided
to talk funny - what's that Thai place
you guys like pop a pieces
it is good and gracious it's so good
[ __ ] was in Japan and Nando's all the
locals don't know about potato man ders
man doesn't [ __ ] man dares you know what
else I think they should do is I heard
koalas are kind of vicious that's what I
heard too you should just [ __ ] shake
a wallet and throw it in the [ __ ]
room but they're sleeping in at 3 a.m.
leave the koala why you stressing out
these cool
koalas I could do that yeah the koalas
having a fun time it's like karate like
they need to get their aggression out I
want to have a fine this has nothing to
do with koalas but have you all seen
videos a pen is eating bamboo yes it's
very conscious [ __ ] hilarious because
it reminds me of myself
cookie dude they never eat bamboo which
is one hand they always got to have to
wiggle one kill and then they know which
parts not fibers they'll ripped off the
husk off with the teeth and for like a
hour I just watching those bills to help
me falsely you know it's weird - there's
no nutritional value or nothing did you
go to channel that [ __ ] eat it for like
so long they have to eat it they can't
anything else either yeah that's all
they use double quite an interesting in
hey guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out up here
[Music]